good evening everyone welcome to what's
been a wonderful week here at the
college with a CCA seminar and now we
cap it off with this final lecture by
Victor Davis Hanson my name is Marc Colt
off I am the chairman of the history
department here at Hillsdale College
where I'm a member of the faculty and
that gives me the privilege of
introducing to you this evening speaker
Victor Davis Hanson is the Martin and
Lily Anderson senior fellow in residence
and classics and military history at
Stanford University's Hoover Institution
he's a mirta's professor of classics at
California State University Fresno where
he founded the classics department most
importantly this evening he is also the
Wayne and MRSA dusky Distinguished
Fellow in history here at Hillsdale
College we're now for the last 15 years
he has traveled to our campus to teach
popular courses in military history and
classical culture every September dr.
Hanson earned his BA in classics at the
University of California Santa Cruz he
attended the American School of
Classical Studies in Athens and earned
his PhD in classics from Stanford
University
among other awards dr. Hansen has
awarded been awarded the National
Humanities medal in 2007 and the Bradley
prize in 2008 he has written or edited
23 books including the other Greeks the
family farm and the agrarian roots of
Western civilization the soul of battle
who killed homer the demise of classical
education and the recovery of Greek
wisdom Mexifornia a state of becoming
which he he talks about the themes of
that book regularly I recommend it
highly also a war like no other and most
recently his book the second world wars
his twenty-fourth book scheduled to
appear early next year will look at the
presidency of Donald Trump beyond his
many books he is the author of hundreds
of articles book reviews scholarly
papers and editorials covering diverse
topics so that range from ancient Greek
culture agrarian themes and military
history to foreign affairs domestic
politics and contemporary culture these
have appeared in almost every
publication that matters including the
New York Times Wall Street Journal Los
Angeles Times International Herald
Tribune New York Post National Review
Washington Time Washington Post's I
could go on many others and he
frequently appears in on television and
radio for NPR PBS Newshour Fox News CNN
and others but beyond these many
professional and scholarly achievements
Victor Hansen has become a dear friend
of many and we at Hillsdale have been
especially blessed by his magnanimity
generosity and kindness even as we have
benefited from and delighted by his
quick mind his good humor and his
uncommon loyalty Thank You Victor please
join me in welcoming our friend
thank you very much for that kind
introduction I wish it was a little less
kind so I wouldn't have pressured not to
disappoint you but what I'd like to do
is put a context into the Trump foreign
policy because we can't really calibrate
what's going on through the media or the
opposition I saw some adjectives and
nouns that a chaos disruption overseas
but to understand I think the Trump
foreign policy we should see how we got
to where we are now and what were the
conditions both foreign and domestic
that created Donald Trump and created
his foreign policy we start with the
so-called post-war order that was the
brilliant creation of American diplomats
Dean Acheson George Kennan George
Marshall Harry Truman Eisenhower after
World War two and remember what the the
rationale was that we had made we had
made a distinct mistake after World War
one that for a variety of reasons we
didn't stay engaged we allowed the
Imperial German army to surrender inside
France and quickly came claimed that
that armistice was a de facto victory
because they surrendered in somebody
else's territory we didn't follow the
advice of John J Pershing a general folk
to go in and occupy Germany as we did in
World War two so we're not going to do
that again at the end of World War two
we also had an ambiguous relationship
with the Soviet Union we had felt that
the Soviet Union and 30s was imploding
the communism didn't work the show
trials the purges of the military class
and especially the 20 million that died
in the collectivization so it was an
odious creation and yet more odious when
it formed the non-aggression pact with
Adolf Hitler on August 23rd 1939 and
then the inexplicable happen we were
still at peace and Germany invaded the
Soviet Union and we made a decision as
early as October of 1941 we
forget that before Pearl Harbor that
under the newly passed lend-lease
legislation we began sending massive aid
to this Soviet Union even as we
understood that was very dangerous to do
should it defeat the Third Reich which
we hoped it would we would have a
problem indeed we did have a problem
after the conclusion of world war ii we
thought to ourselves we're gonna stay
engaged and it was a great thing that we
destroyed the Third Reich and the
Japanese Empire but in the process of
that we've created another monster and
it's as godless and dangerous as the
Third Reich and it's Soviet global
communism and unfortunately one of the
tragedies of world war two is that the
Soviet Army is now not a thousand miles
away from the English Channel there is
no free and autonomous Eastern Europe
was one of the great tragedies we went
to war for the freedom suppose we being
in the Allies first Britain and then
later in France and then later us but
the concept was to keep Eastern Europe
free ie Poland from German aggression
and we ended up ensuring that it would
not be free and we moved the borders of
the Soviet Union not just to Germany
which had there had been a buffer now
these communist satellite wars our packs
were not just at the border of the the
old German Empire they're now in an
interior border right on the edge of
what we call West Germany and they were
350 miles from the English Channel and
they had 500 divisions and our strategy
of fighting World War two had been the
great Soviet juggernut who will kill two
out of every three German soldiers will
not have a Navy it will not have an Air
Force it will not have a u-boat Air Arm
it will not fight in Italy it will not
fight North Africa it will not fight
Japan but it will just stay there and
like a bulldog destroy the German army
and they did but again the paradox was
when the war was over it was the biggest
army in the world we had a hundred
divisions in Europe and they had 500 and
they were Pope poised to go right into
the chain
and they could anytime we want it they
wanted so we said we're going to check
Soviet power both to a nuclear deterrent
and we're going to fight pay any price
as John Kennedy anywhere any how to stop
this menace and remember one of the
reasons that we did it we said that
there is no other alternative
Japan is destroyed it's not the Japan of
today not the third-largest economy it's
got a zero economy and Germany is
destroyed it's not the fourth largest
economy of today it's destroyed and
there is no Chinese miracle 15 million
people have died in China from Japanese
occupation Dargis economy as it is today
and there is no you EU that France has
been occupied and nine other European
countries west and the East Eastern
Europeans there's nobody but us in Great
Britain and Great Britain has decided to
national their steel nationalize their
steal their oil their communications or
health in Rome and they're not going to
be in a position to take advantage of a
world market at their feet it was only
us if we didn't rebuild Europe nobody
else was so we created these post-war
institutions the World Bank the general
agreement on tariffs and trade the
United Nations
you remember NATO North Atlantic Treaty
Organization remember the motto of NATO
keep Russia out general Ismay said keep
America in and keep Germany down and
that that theory that paradigm that
blueprint that we crafted these
brilliant diplomats worked wonderfully
for forty five years and that by that I
mean the Chinese Communists did not
absorb all of Asia they turned on the
Soviets as we wanted the Soviet Union
did not take Europe and we paid a
terrible price for that we spent between
four and five percent GDP and sometimes
we peaked at ten and twelve in Vietnam
in Korea we lost over ninety thousand
dead more than the European theater of
operations
Normandy to Germany in World War two in
places like Korea and Vietnam and we
became the world's policemen and it
worked so in 1989 40 left Lee 45 years
44 years after it this this idea of a
post World Order worked and it should
have been done we're done we did what we
wanted to do and indeed people said with
the collapse of the Soviet Union in the
Berlin fall Wall fell in 1989 the United
States won the Cold War
Ronald Reagan's deterrent policies
during the administration of successor
George HW Bush journey Germany was
united remember against the objections
of Margaret Thatcher in 1990 it was
United Francis Fukuyama wrote his
landmark I guess it's a landmark book I
wouldn't necessarily agree but in 1992
it was called the end of history it took
the theme that Hegel had remarked at the
Battle of Jena and 1806 when Napoleon
marched in and he said basically the old
order is over with Anna Paulette and the
partly onic idea of a revolutionary
society of equals will now be the
paradigm that throughout Europe history
is over as we knew it there's no other
paradigm to what Napoleon uh sure did
Fukuyama said whether we like it or not
and we do like it we won the Cold War
and there's no alternative to
free-market capitalism and
constitutional government and freedom of
the individual and there's not going to
be any more war we won and no sooner had
he written that then the Balkans
exploded and as you remember he was
writing that just he year after the
first Gulf War in which we found out
that Saddam Hussein might have gotten
nuclear weapons we don't know but the
Middle East was not stable and they
didn't think the world the end of
history had come Milosevic did not think
the end of history had come Noriega
didn't think the end of history had come
and so the Iranians did not think with
their hostage at the end of history had
come so we had this post-war idea that
containment
and being the world's policeman that
continued in to a new phase and the
conditions which created it no longer
existed there was no longer a third
reich to defeat and there was no longer
a soviet union to contain but we again
felt we were now the hyper power the
unit power was not a bipolar world was a
unipolar nobody had as much strength as
we did and we were going to continue the
success at great cost to us and expense
because it was going to be much cheaper
than the alternative so we said we were
going to protect the free world we
didn't even use that word anymore
because of course at the end of history
everybody was going to be free but we
were going to be the leader that so much
very similar to what Rome was you
classicists might remember that Edward
Gibbon said the greatest period of
prosperity in the history of
civilization was the hundred years
starting with the m4 Nerva Trajan and
Hadrian Antonius Pius and Marcus
Aurelius in which there was no war there
was no famine and there were no
contentious issues because all of
mankind seventy million people within a
million square miles were all in the
same page and that was a vote again and
again that that's what we were after
1989 and 91 so we were going to be like
Rome and every once in a while
jagira or Mithra daddy's or
Vercingetorix some thug in Panama as I
said or some thug like Saddam Hussein or
that they would sprout up and we would
hit them down for the sake of the world
and this world order that it was still
pretty much what it was after World War
two and all of these hollowed in
institutions NATO you and we would not
question and then we had 9/11 and 9/11
was strange and the anniversary of
course was yesterday but the Japanese
and the Germans and the Soviets had
never taken down
a high you know high rise right in the
middle of Manhattan or killed 3,000
Americans so this was a new threat and
we thought well the new war against
terror will be operated in the same way
we
we fought the Soviets will still take on
the burden this responsibility the
burden of defense of the West against
radical Islam it's a ill liberal
doctrine that threatens Western freedom
but what we didn't realize is due to our
very success in the first phase of 45
years and the second one and remember
this second phase since 1989 we're still
in that we're in the 30th year of it
before after the fall of the Berlin Wall
and we're still supposed to be the
keeper of the values of the West to
defeat the Soviet unit now it's
transferred to these local thugs and
radicalism but the problem is did the
world change and were the premises of
the post-war world order where they
still valid and there were starting to
be disturbing indications that while we
still respected these institutions and
we subsidize them and we intervened
for the world order and we spent more
than the next 19 military budgets in the
world and we still lost Americans all
over the globe other people didn't think
that we were doing this for them or our
enemies did not think the end of history
was here so we started to examine the
last four or five years certain
questions I mean they were they were
they were not cut and dried issues the
new world order the post-war world had
assumed remember that democratization
would put us in this end of history so
we had a country like China we said to
ourselves there's a billion people we
need to bring it into the family of
democratic nations and according to
people at the Hoover Institution where I
work the more affluence you have the
more you have a free market even if it's
a quasi free market the more
liberalisation inevitably follows so we
said to ourselves over the last thirty
years if they cheat baby in the Chinese
on patents it's okay they're eventually
going to be wealthy and then they'll be
democratic if they cheat on copyright
there are wealthy there'll be democratic
if they dump on the world market it
doesn't matter if they run up a 350
billion dollar surplus it doesn't matter
if they go into the Spratly Islands and
violate local treaties with the
Philippines or Vietnam Japan doesn't
matter because they're getting wealthier
and they're getting more like us they
wear suits and ties they come to Silicon
Valley it doesn't matter
and all of a sudden we decided I don't
think that we said collectively I don't
think they're gonna become democratic in
fact I think they're using free markets
at the direction of the government to be
the next Soviet Union they're becoming
more powerful than we are and yet the
status quo of the post-war order the
Council of Foreign Relations the main
think tanks Brookings American
Enterprise Institute Hoover Institution
the government department at Harvard the
council and all these people said no no
they're gonna be they're gonna be
they're going to be democratic they're
gonna eventually going to be one of us
and we have to take that hit remember
also what the rationale of the post-war
war order was that since the rest of the
world is flat and they're not they don't
have the wherewithal to be the global
policeman and the global economic power
in the global market for new newly
recovering countries to export and run
up surpluses we do we do we do we heard
that for 75 years we're so powerful
we're so rich we can do it and we can
take a 350 billion dollar surplus with
China we were so rich we looked at
Europe well Europe was not the same the
last 10 years as it was this a EU this
European Union we thought was going to
be a common market and then it was going
to expand to sort of a common alliance
it was going to be an adjunct maybe of
NATO we didn't realize that this was
some kind of Bonaparte as utopian scheme
that they were going to outlaw a war
they were going to open their borders to
the people of the world they were going
to be leaders in climate change they
were going to disarm they were going to
have
and act basically a democratic socialist
paradigm and we were going to defend
them and they were going to get very
angry that we defended them and we said
to ourselves if we can do this so if if
Germany has a sixty five billion dollar
trade surplus with us or during the 2003
war if the EU all of the countries have
dammed us and they France votes against
it it's okay because this is the
post-war order that's what we're
supposed to do and then we said Germany
is the most powerful country it's got 80
million it's it's historically been
dangerous but we solved the problem
because it's in the EU and it's in NATO
then people started to say well wait a
minute the last ten years the pew the
Pew poll said that Germany poles of all
countries in Europe the most
anti-american under Obama was 53% of
Germans like the United States today
it's 37% it Italians like Americans at
twice over his Germans and as I said
they're running a 65 billion and they
have dictated financial terms to the
southern credit debtor nations Greece
Italy Spain Portugal they have dictated
immigration issues to Poland Romania
Hungary and the Czech Republic
they have dictated the conditions of
brexit to the UK and they have told us
we're spending 1.4 percent of our GDP on
defense and we're not going to go up and
meet our promises at two percent and
we've said to them if you don't invest
two percent how are we going to get the
Belgians and how are we gonna get the
Dutch and how are we gonna get the
Norwegians to do it and meet there
because they follow your lead and you're
cutting a potentially large deal with
Putin at four hundred billion dollars in
yet you want us to defend you from Putin
what's going on this doesn't this isn't
part of the post war didn't it wasn't
supposed to work like that and then we
looked at Russia and we thought at the
end of communism
Yeltsin is a is one of us we've sent of
all of our Harvard economists over there
Russians are meeting us they love us
they're gonna make Harvard a Yale there
it's gonna be a liberal democracy it's
got oil and that didn't happen it sort
of became an autocratic oligarchic you
know let's be it's an orthodox country
it's deeply religious it it didn't seem
the liberal country that we had counted
on we looked at the EU to take the
entire EU and we said wow the demography
is not even replacing its population
it's one point for half of the churches
are empty it's a secular country they
have no means or ability or desire to
assimilate intermarry or integrate
Muslim immigrants it seems foreign to us
but that's not supposed to be part of
the post-war order and the subtext of
all this was we can do it because with
the wealthiest country in the world but
under the tenants of globalization which
were went hand in glove with American
post-war leadership people started to
say well I'm starting to catch on to
globalization and that is we take a big
to 365 billion dollar hit with the
Chinese 65 billion with the Germans 75
billion with the Mexican government 75
billion second only to Germany excuse me
to China it's bigger than the German and
we let 330 million excuse me 30 billion
dollars in remittances go back to Mexico
half of whom are being subsidized by the
US government the people who send that
money back but we can do it we're
wealthy we can be a NAFTA we have the
Canadians or wonderful people if we have
a small fifteen billion dollar definite
thats not a problem if germany has the
largest account surplus in the world
larger even than china in terms of
financial service in the whole picture
at over three hundred billion we can do
it
and then we started to look at places
like Hillsdale County or southern Fresno
County and we started to see something
that was very striking that we I say we
it wasn't we it were people that we
wrote off as nuts that were questioning
the post-war order or were disruptive
our chaotic they started to say certain
things and they said I've come to the
conclusion that under this second phase
of the post-war order we have an
ossified foreign policy and military
policy and strategic policy that doesn't
fit this changing world
that doesn't fit the new China or the
new EU or South America didn't become
all democratic it's because it's
reverting to socialism or the more we
reach out to Iran it's not working but
what is happening is that anybody who
has a job that involves muscular labor
and that job can be xeroxed overseas it
will be xeroxed overseas and this divide
is is destroying this country culturally
socially geographically because we're
creating two very wealthy cultures from
Florida to Boston and from La Jolla to
Seattle and they're in culture in taste
in affinity closer in the west coast to
maybe Shanghai and Tokyo and the east
coast to London in Paris than they are
to Hillsdale this is the this is the
interior culture and these interior
culture people that work assembling
products or the industrial heart of
America that won World War two that had
a greater GDP than all the other
combatants and allies together have been
hollowed out because they can have their
job replicated and the people in the
coast can china can't build a Stanford
University yet Japan still hasn't
figured out quite - to match our hedge
fund as one person I gave a talk not too
long ago a very angry person that said
mr. Hanson you wake up one morning and
find somebody did your column for half
the price from South Korea I said no
that hasn't happened yet
he said when it will you know how I feel
and the point was that we were sorry to
say that these were the deplorable ''s
clingers Expendables
they were the losers of globalization we
went the next step and said it wasn't
just that they lost out but they
deserved to lose down they didn't move
they took math it was almost as if they
they developed the pathology and then
the industry left rather than what
really happened industries left and then
they developed the pathologies so this
post-war order had not caught up to
these new global realities and we tried
to adjust 2009 to 2016 Barack Obama came
in with a new foreign policy and give
him credit he understood that the old
George W Bush going into Iraq or
Afghanistan or Georgia it's not the same
thing anymore but he took he took this
evidence and he came up with a very
disturbing conclusion and he said the
reason it's not working is our fault
because we try to impose our will on
people and who's to say that the United
States Democratic liberal Society is any
better than what's in Iran and you know
we always bought back these Gulf
monarchies in Israel but maybe Iran
should be a legitimate hegemon and maybe
we should who were to say that we can
dictate to them when they get nuclear
weapons so we'll do this around deal and
we got a the reason that we haven't had
a Palestinian solution is that because
we've been backing the wrong people the
Israelis are intolerant or a liberal and
it doesn't really matter that we have
capitalist countries in Latin America
maybe Venezuela and Nicaragua or Cuba
has a better paradigm and the EU is
pretty good we should be more like the
EU than the EU should be like us and he
didn't address the people in the
interior he furthered that diagnosis
they deserved what they got so now we've
spent 25 minutes and you can see what's
going to end up somebody comes along and
says he's on a stage with 16 Republican
nominees he has no military experience
and he has never served in political
office and he doesn't give a blank blank
about the Council on Foreign Relations
he doesn't care about NATO he looks at
this as a businessman and he says it's a
bad deal he looks at optional Wars like
a reality TV show they have there if you
go into somewhere you usually get bad
ratings and it doesn't work out on a
cost-benefit analysis so that's what's
his idea about going into Libya for
example and so he's not wedded to any of
these things and he starts to look at
the world
empirically that's changed radically
from the post-war orders second phase
was supposed to deal with it
and he add the Obama aberrancy and he
starts to come up with crazy ideas crazy
to them maybe not so crazy to us and he
said I like NATO all they got to do
they're wealthy countries the GDP of
Europe and the populations greater and
just pay what they promised don't pay as
much as we do but just pay we pay 4% GDP
into military expending you pay too if
you don't know how to do it and we're
gonna leave well I don't think he was
gonna leave but that was what he said
and he said to Mexico you know what we
might have to close the border we might
have to yank out some of the factories
and the trade deals and we might have to
put a tariff on products that are sent
back people said you can't use the word
tariff that's not part of the post-war
order and basically Trump said well I
don't really want to pretend that's art
of the deal I threatened I threatened I
threatened and they'll back down maybe
from 350 billion surplus to 2 billion
that's a victory but nobody never
thought like that before he was
endangering the post-war order and he
looked at the world throughout and he
started to come up with a foreign policy
and they actually memorialized it in
2017 if you take looked at the strategic
plan of the United States and national
security assessment written by HR
McMaster and his team it's pretty much
called principled realism and it is a
complete rejection of 75 years of
foreign policy of the United States and
it's predicated on the idea that foreign
policy and domestic policy are
inseparable
and there were certain shibboleths there
that we should recognize for what they
are China the wealthier it's going to be
is going to be more autocratic the
Palestinians are never going to be
democratic until they on their own throw
out their corrupt elite and we can't
help them do that anymore
and Saudi Arabia and Egypt and Jordan
are probably not going to be democratic
but they're better than the alternative
in Iran radical Shia you know messianic
expansionary Islam and Latin America is
likely to be communist as capitalist but
if we have our druthers we're going to
support capitalist states and not
communist and you start to read it you
it was termed Jacksonian don't tread on
me foreign policy and what that meant
was I think if you read it carefully it
means we're not going to seek trouble in
the world we're not going to be the
world's policemen but we are going to
deter our enemies and we will strike
back if they strike us back and we may
have to preempt once in a while and that
will make a safer world and it might
have the same effect but we're not going
to claim that every single struggle in
the world is of interest to somebody in
Hillsdale County because we've seen
where that leads economically
domestically and we're going to start be
asking for we have two doctrines of the
new Jacksonian ISM as I understand it
I'm not being an advocate I'm trying to
explain to you this one is if what they
are doing doesn't matter why did they do
it if you thinks trade surpluses don't
matter then why does Germany want them
why don't they just be like us and say
they don't matter we'll run a deficit
with you who cares well who has the
trade surplus we'll just take the
tariffs on you know American cars and
we'll do the same thing as you guys have
you have two and a half percent on the
audio will have two half percent in the
four or if China if trade deficits don't
matter we'll run up a three billion
dollar bill ioan dollars surplus and
China will have a three and that was
sort of the logic that Trump of course
used that was the first thing
and the second was that I'm going to
calibrate foreign policy in terms of how
it affects people this was kind of scary
sometime and that mean if we want to
stay in Afghanistan what is the effect
on the people have to go over there
what's the effect on the US budget and
is it really possible to turn
Afghanistan into Carmel California and
if so at what cost
that was the that's in this the
principle realism and so what made it
even stranger was that once we saw this
new Trump foreign policy that said I'm
looking at everything empirically NATO
is 65 years old if it works here I'm
willing to subsidize it if you guys want
to participate NAFTA is there but it's
not written in stone I'm willing to keep
going if it's reciprocal I'm willing to
still trade with China if they get out
of it if they don't if they follow the
rules and the way that we follow the
rules and everybody said but we always
took a hit we always took a hit for the
greater good he said it's not the
greater good and we can't afford to take
the hit we've done it for 75 years and
we've hollowed out the interior so that
was a very powerful message that got him
nominated in ways that 16 other
brilliant candidates did not see and
it's enraged the establishment in the
university and the think tanks and the
foundations and the political bipartisan
establishment and yet he wrote it all
out it was it's not just herky-jerky
it's written right out an assessment
that we have a new principle realism for
a radically different world that doesn't
look anything like our foreign policy
that was formed in 1945 for a very
different world and if I could sort of
summarize it and just a phrase it's Jim
mattis gave a speech once and I think he
summarized it it's no better friend no
worse enemy that the world is not full
of neutrals anymore and there's not
going to be a global community and
there's not going to be utopian we're
situation or there it's not going to be
a postmodern globe where we're all
climate change advocates and we all
believe
and gender rights and it's not going to
happen there's going to be local
differences there's gonna be tribalism
there's going to be chaos all over the
world as there is as I speak right now
and what we're going to do is pretty
much look at people that we have more
than less in common with and support
them they're going to be our friends and
people we feel are disruptors or don't
like this American system we're gonna be
enemies too and that's going to make
actually because we're a unique
exceptional country and we have better
judgment than these global organizations
like the UN that's gonna make a safer
world abroad and it's going to have a
don't tread on me X don't attack the
United States don't point missiles at
Portland Oregon don't cheat on trade
don't fortify that or something might
happen to you and we're gonna make that
decision with the allies that we can and
by ourself if we must let me just finish
by saying there's two other things I
think are very important to understand
this end of the post-war world and why
this strange fellow from Manhattan real
estate entrepreneur was able to craft a
message that kind of fit the world as we
see it rather than the world as we would
like it and yet it had dramatic
electoral ramifications because he
appealed to people who were the losers
of globalization and resonated with one
is you would think that it wouldn't work
because he would be ostracized by all
the institutions that fed people into a
typical Republican administration so you
see all of these notable diplomats they
have billets at the most prestigious
things and they write op-eds almost
every day he's doing story in the world
anybody who would serve in that
administration we should be ashamed and
yet when you look at the four or five
architects or tasked with carrying this
out they're the finest finest foreign
policy team since we've since in World
War two you'll never find a better
defense secretary than James Madison
Peale is a brilliant if you look at his
activity compared to a John Kerry or Rex
Tillerson or Hillary
Clinton there's no there's no comparison
if you look at nikki Haley what she's
doing at the UN if you look at John
Bolton his national security place these
are all excellent point how can that be
and it's because there were a lot of
people in Washington who were not duly
appreciated because they saw that the
post-war order was not working to a
vastly changed world and when they spoke
out against that they were ostracized or
that you had to bring people from
different walks of life into that
administration and I'll end with the
comment we talked about the Trump
economic boom or the Trump revolution
but I would suggest you do that what
we're doing in foreign policy is far
more radical and far more important
because it's the only system that we can
see that we've seen that has a answer or
at least address things that were
considered either not our business our
insolvable so we we just look at the
world knew and we say think about it
we're liberated you cannot get out of
there and deal why not
he'd never sent it to the treaty he
never had it ratified by the Senate we
got out it's over with Mitt Romney would
have never done that you cannot say that
the Palestinians are not refugees why
the Volga Germans were refugees the same
year they were are they still called
refugees 13 million Russians walked back
East Germans to Germany they were
refugees are not anymore why the
Palestinians special they're not no more
refugees no more embassy Jerusalem has
always been the historical and iconic
capital of Israel just move it you can't
do that just do it so we did it and on
and on and on and that's a very
liberating attitude and it's starting to
have much more ramifications even than
the booming economy which is part and
parcel of the foreign policy so I guess
what I'm saying in conclusion is that
this foreign policy besides being
principle realism and looking for allies
and then accepting that people won't
like us and shouldn't like us and we
don't like them and they should we
shouldn't like them it's also saying the
world is back to 1946 again
and we're looking at it empirically and
we're trying to come up with new
solutions and some of the solutions
should have been done a long time ago
and rather than be radical and
revolutionary they're way overdue thank
you very much
Thank You dr. Hansen we now have time
for a few questions please raise your
hand and wait for a microphone to be
brought to you
we have a question to the speakers right
did I understand you to say that there
is an outline of rational coherent
foreign policy paper and has never been
publicized and never been explained how
did that I can I can assure you that if
you go on to Google tonight and you look
at the national security assessment or
national security policy you'll see that
it was released in December of 2017 it
was authored by HR McMaster and the term
that's used the most as the word
principal realism and the theme of it is
that the United States is looking at
everything from a new point of view and
not locked into a post-war order that no
longer mirrors a situation that we have
what why is it that everybody doesn't
know that well John John Bolton knows it
and Trump knows it and Pompeyo knows it
and that's why there
[Applause]
so that that's why they're saying
certain things that they're not supposed
to be saying they're saying North Korea
cannot point missiles at Portland and
San Diego and then extort us it's not
going to be a situation and they're
saying the Iranians are gonna have to
have spot inspections they're not going
to use that four hundred billion dollars
that they're going to get in the next 20
years from this deal to subsidize
terrorism and there is no as far as
we're concerned Palestinians are gonna
have to come up with their own
government and deal in a bilateral but
we're not going to subsidize that
project and on and on and on and NATO is
going to have to pay that's all in there
and it's the idea is that it hasn't been
good for the people that we're dealing
with to subsidize them psychologically
or financially and there's never been a
power in history that that subsidizes
other powers that they like them for
that so if you want to know why the
Europeans don't like us sometimes are
they ankle bite us it's because we
subsidize our defense and if we can
become full partners with us they'll
like us more but they won't unless they
have forced to human nature being what
it is we have a question to the speakers
left in terms of trade has bought chain
had a major impact on the way we view
our trading partners in terms the way we
deal with our trading partners because
with blockchain we can now detect
cheating on the part of the Canadians
and the Mexicans and in terms of
transshipping things I think it has
there's been a lot of things that have
changed our ideas of trade one of them
was that you remember when Barack Obama
said what is he going to do have a magic
wand and bring jobs back they're gone
and he quoting him literally not just
figuratively and so we said in this new
way of thinking why isn't it possible
you go to Europe I go to Europe we see
people working American
work pretty hard why can't an America
know how if we can build the world's
best universities and jets why can't we
have the best industrial sector and so
if it's a free if it's and we have the
technology as you point out to ascertain
who is cheating and who's not cheating
and why would they want to cheat if
cheating doesn't matter that's what
we've been told
and if cheating does matter and we're
willing to accept it because it's for
the good of the world it what if it
isn't for the good of the world what if
we're just empowering the Chinese Navy
in a way that we wouldn't if they were
had to deal according to the normal
commercial protocols everybody else has
to do but we had gotten in such a rut
that just to suggest these things was
and atham and the final thing is if you
think if you try to tell Mexico we'd
we'd like to help you and we want to
bring you up to Canada's level of
prosperity and I know that we used to
think that that was by running up these
huge trade surpluses but it's really
your fault you're not transparent you
don't have an independent judiciary you
don't have property rights you don't
have truly constitutional elections and
when you do you'll be as prosperous as
Canada but in the meantime we're not
going to subsidize it anymore and so
when you start to talk like that what
mechanisms do you have other than sobers
and judicious diplomats met at a summit
and both said it was helpful and
constructive that's what we did and so
Trump comes along and part of the deal
you know he uses the t-word tariff but
there is no other coercion you can use
except a threat to do the unmentionable
so now he's a protectionist and all that
but what he's trying to do is act crazy
and unstable and then somebody and his
economic team or his national security
team goes eh he bothers me anymore than
he does you but you guys in Europe or
you guys in Japan or you guys I'm trying
to deal with us before you have to deal
with him so that's what he's doing
he wrote about it I mean if you read art
of the deal order to come back all those
books it's pretty transparent the only
thing I'm worried about is the enemies
read the books do and they're gonna say
you know what he's bluffing
we have a question near the center of
the room Thank You fellow California
native I'm Walt a legal immigrant Tuukka
Florida you focus on foreign policy but
do you have a view on the convention of
states as a viable to amend the
Constitution well I mean in theory yes
but when you get them all together as we
know we don't know what's going to
happen so they're all most states are
like individual voters and so I know
things are bad but I can imagine they
could be a lot worse
and so what protects us is the
Constitution that we've had for we're in
our third century so I I don't want to
do that yet so I'd say no on that but
maybe it's because I've seen how
democracy works in California and
everything that's destroyed the state is
was voted on by the the people or the
legislature or it was enacted by the
court so I understand your frustration
but I don't think you want to get a
bunch of states together and then - I'll
just add very quickly what's dangerous
about this sectarianism this red blue
it's a it's not like the sixties words
left right it's more like the 1850s
because there's a geographical element
that's a force multiplier it's not just
that when I go back to California the
way people talk and eat and their the
way that they're there their lifestyles
are the hipsters
what's the streets of San Francisco in
Michigan or Ohio but they're the same as
the coast and the in the West and East
Coast and so we're creating two cultures
that are not just culture but they're
geographically distinct and that's what
we did in the Civil War
and so when you see the Trump rallies
and then you see the people who are
standing up at the Kavanagh hearings and
screaming you've got two people who live
in geographically different places and
they don't like each other they don't
have much in common
so it's kind of scary very scary we have
a question up right here yes do you have
any thoughts on the change in our
monetary policies over the last say Oh
pre Bretton Woods to now and what will
happen in the future I know that's a lot
of topic that kind of thing how we
manage money I know we'll never go back
to gold standard thing I didn't mention
is that part of the second phase of the
post-war order was predicated on taking
serious debts and making them almost
unsustainable so George Bush almost in
seven years not quite eight he doubled
the debt and then brock obama ran is a
physical conservative and said you took
the back bank of china credit card you
remember that i said and you doubled and
then he doubled the debt and that was
all predicated on near zero interest
rates so if you look at the amount of
money that we were paying when obama
left office and to service a almost
twenty trillion dollar debt it wasn't
all that much more than Bill Clinton was
paying at 7% interest for a six trillion
dollar debt but we got to the point
where we thought zero interest rates was
a new norm and one of the things we've
seen with Trump is the interest rate
starts to go up a little bit it's
actually helping the economy because we
basically confiscated about three
trillion dollars over the last twenty
years from people like yourself that
save money and you put it in a passbook
account you got zero interest and then
people were able to borrow borrow money
very cheaply so that's starting to end a
little bit and it's going to be very
tricky because if we have this labor six
million jobs are going on filled we have
the economy's heating up it's probably
going to grow at nearly four percent GDP
and inflation and we have this big debt
and yet
there's not too many things you can do
if we get into an economic crisis
because we've used them all we have a
big debt we have almost low interest
what else are you going to do to
stimulate the economy so I think we've
got a trump at some point if he gets
reelected it's gonna have to pivot and
do some things that might be called
deflationary or at least in dress
address entitlements and debt and
budgetary concerns because if the budget
deficits are not sustainable the Social
Security system is not sustainable and
to to rectify that is pretty dramatic
and it's going to cause a lot of hurt to
people but it's gonna have to be done
now or will be done much more abruptly
in the future we have a question toward
the back of the room yeah I something
you mentioned brought me back to
something very mundane back to the
fundamentals as a former coach
fundamentals are very important you
mentioned the importance of the
Constitution the Constitution by our
last president was considered an
obsolete document he mentioned that more
on more than on once at one occasion
executive orders have been abused by
many presidents they were meant to be
used within the agencies that answer to
the president have extended beyond that
and then you have the judicial branch
that has taken over the executive the
Congressional and its own branch
it's the judiciary is out of control at
this point
what can how can we look at this in a
way that we can start to get back to the
fundamentals well it's a very good
question you see because in some ways
Donald Trump was created by Barack Obama
and by that I mean when Donald Trump has
been very successful with just one big
signature tax package but what has
jump-started this economy is a series of
executive orders I don't know the
constitutional al aliy of each one but
what he's done is he's deregulated he's
opened up a noir he's had an executive
order on
stone he's muzzled the EPA and he's
using the executive branch in lieu of
the legislative branch and he's he's
been thwarted by the court so he's
trying to get you know conservative
constitutional judges but it depends on
I guess he would say they made the rules
and I'm using them now against them but
I don't know to what degree Trump has
violated any executive order that I know
is one of the ironies that were in this
political system were saying well Donald
Trump was saying the fake news he's
heard them but he hasn't he hasn't
monitored the Associated Press
journalist he hasn't monitored the
emails of a fox reporter he hasn't
weaponized the IRS to go after people he
hasn't jailed a video maker he hasn't
gone into a FISA Court and said I'm not
gonna give you the complete story about
this dossier so and his his rhetoric is
alarming but when you actually look at
who was alarming was a malicious Obama
because he took these the CIA the DOJ
the FBI
he took all of these these deep state
permanent bureaucracies and he he really
tried to affect the outcome of the 2016
election with John Brennan and and
clapper and Comey and all and mccabe and
yet any monitored people and he did a
lot of very radical things he said he
couldn't be a king twenty-one times are
to the effect of that and then he went
around and did dhaka and the dreamer act
and pretty much destroyed federal
immigration law and then he said he
allowed these cities to say and I'm
living one that's a sanctuary City if
Hillsdale tomorrow says I'm a sanctuary
city anybody in Hillsdale Township does
not have to follow federal gun
registration just go buy a gun nobody's
gonna get worse sanctuary city or you
know what if you see a 3 spotted towed
that's on the endangered shoot the thing
in the head this is a sanctuary city you
can imagine what California would say
but it's all one way they can they can
nullify and you can see where it goes it
goes back to the nullification crisis of
1826 of South Carolina in the 1850s so
we've just coming off a very radical
president that for some reason his
supporters now are shocked that Donald
Trump he hasn't done what he's what
Obama did but he sounds radical but I
don't I don't pay much attention I don't
think we should it's what people do not
what they say question to the speakers
left would you mind sharing your
thoughts a little bit about the coming
midterm select midterm elections maybe
best-case scenario and worst-case
scenario and what we can do as
conservatives well the worst-case
scenario would be that some of these
liberal prognosis are right about the
Senate that they could take the Senate
and that would mean they'd have to win
races like the Cruz race or something if
that would happen they would impeach him
in the house and then we would have an
acrimonious impeachment in the Senate
with a lot of pressure on moderate Ben
Sasse like Republicans to join what
would be a majority already to get six
votes and that would pretty much stall
or destroy the Trump agenda that would
be the worst case scenario I don't think
they would impeach him but it would be
long and drawn-out much more than the
Clinton impeachment the best-case
scenario is we usually lose I think it's
27 seats in a midterm election the first
year that Trump somehow would would buck
historical trends he lose four or five
seats in a house he retained the house
he retained the Senate and that would be
seen as a devastating setback to this
what we saw at the Kavanagh hearing or
the anonymous op-ed or the Woodward
brook that whole cycle of D legitimizing
the president so which is which it just
depends on two things and I don't have
the answer to it nobody seems to and
that is how in a midterm election how
mobilized are the Trump base in other
words when they see the Cavanaugh
hearings are they read about the New
York Times so they say that's terrible
but it's a midterm or they say that's so
terrible I'm going to go out and vote
for my candidate and then we don't know
the effect of all these things on the
independent so-called voter we found out
in 2016 that just think for a minute in
2016 the night of the election the New
York Times published three polls and
they said there's 1% chance that
Trumpkin when there's nine percent
chance and there's 16% and we're not
even a mention Nate salt of silver he's
so pessimistic he's giving Trump 27%
chance of winning that's where we were
so we're hearing this it's kind of eerie
we're hearing the same thing about the
midterm blue wave Trump is people get
sick of him but we don't know whether
that same that same phenomenon is there
it seems to me that I don't when I see
people and they're for Trump they don't
want to talk about it whether or not for
Trump they yell about it because they
understand the social consequences of
each and if that is still true that I
think he's being underreported by two or
three percent and the people who support
him more but we're gonna have to wait to
the midterm
any final questions
I don't know how we are in time yeah sir
I've heard you talk about Athenian
society and the quieting that took place
there when a good chunk of its people
became dissatisfied with the culture
that did not represent them do you think
we have that going on now and
essentially how do we get back to being
friends with each other yeah well you're
speaking to someone that grew up with
three siblings and two first cousins
that were part of my family and of my
four siblings if it's this gonna be
aired I guess it might be on tape two of
them voted for I suppose Bernie Sanders
and two voted for Hillary Clinton so and
they they made me they made me aware of
it but and so what we want to do is when
we see people who vote differently than
we do we don't want to make that the
sole criteria of how we treat each other
we can say there's all different factors
that lead to that wrong decision on
their part but and we don't want to hold
a grudge we don't want to hold a grudge
so what I try to do is if I have to give
a lecture and somebody disrupts it or
somebody yells or I get I mean I live in
California I work at Stanford so I'm in
a situation with nine out of ten people
don't agree with me and one or two will
come up and tell you that so you want to
not take it seriously you don't want to
have a vendetta you don't want to warp
your soul and that's what would happen
you don't want to end up hating and yet
you don't want to be a pacifist either
you have to be firm and you because if
you're not firm you don't help the cause
you don't help the people that trust as
you do but you don't want to end up
hating somebody or despising somebody
you know so I try to look for the good
part and everybody I hope they treat me
the same I do think though that I'll
just end with this comment there's
something about the current left the
progressive left
that's holistic in a way that the right
isn't by that I mean people who are
conservative
they were willing to put politics in a
simple part of their life but they have
spheres subordinate spheres that are not
contaminated by politics you don't
really care what the politics of a
football player are you would like to
see the Oscars or the Emmys just to give
the print that you don't want to hear a
lecture at the Miss America contest you
want to turn on late-night comedy and
not be lectured but the left feels that
because their goals are so noble of
radical egalitarianism that it justifies
any means necessary and that means that
the university's entertainment Hollow in
every aspect of our lives in a very
Orwellian way has to be politicized and
weaponized and that's what we're all
upset about we don't want a war we just
want to say our discord we just want to
say give us some peace so out once we
get out of the political realm when we
go to a football game or turn on music
or watch a TV show we don't have that
24/7 indoctrination and for them they
can't do that because they feel they're
morally superior and there are war and
me any means are justified because of
their noble goals that's the difference
between us
[Applause]